[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale il est
télévision locale vous présente
le club des territoires
et avec nous pour ce club Stéphane
Vernet de Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane
alexandre Poussin merci également vous
nous avez rejoint et faire le point
évidemment sur les résultats dans nos
départements nos employés spéciaux et
journalistes de la presse régionale
Samira de chez Rita Lille dans le Nord
Steve Jourdain est à Paris Audrey à
Nanterre dans les Hauts-de-Seine et puis
pierre Mathis du journal L'Indépendant
est à Perpignan dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales on vous retrouve
dans quelques instants d'abord on va
regarder ce qui se dessine comme le
nouvel hémicycle du Sénat on le rappelle
ce sont des projections puisque les
sénateurs ont quelques jours pour
s'inscrire dans les groupes on a donc
fait ça à partir des déclarations des
présidents de groupe les républicains
qui pourraient perdre quelques sièges
les centristes eux qui pourraient en
gagner environ trois ou quatre les
socialistes qui devraient également
gagner quelques sièges ou sièges au
moins se maintenir c'est ce que nous
disait à l'instant Patrick canner les
écologistes qui sortiraient également
gagnants quatre sièges a priori les
communes qui pourraient également gagner
deux ou trois et Renaissance qui en
perdrait mais François Patriat nous le
redisa à l'instant il ne passeront pas à
sous la barre des ordinateurs ils
étaient 24 et puis évidemment l'autre
fait marquant c'est l'entrée du
rassemblement national vous le voyez le
RN qu'il a de manière sûre contrat trois
sénateurs Jean-Baptiste Daoulas quand
vous regardez cette hémicie qu'est-ce
que vous vous dites finalement c'est la
stabilité au Sénat c'est une fausse
stabilité parce qu'en fait dans ces
cases qui est assez passionnant quand on
regarde c'est qu'on a l'impression que
les forces restent globalement assez
inchangés puisque ça joue à trois ou
quatre sièges à peu près à chaque fois
mais c'est toujours passionnant de
regarder vraiment dans les détails ce
que ce que trois sénateurs du
rassemblement national dit sur et bien
le changement aussi sociologique et
politique des petits élus qui
sont pas c'est pas tous des gens en
Carter rassemblement national qu'on voté
pour ces trois sénateurs donc c'est
assez passionnant sur ce que ça dit de
sur ce que sur ce que ça dit deux à ce
qui est assez passionnant c'est regarder
également le l'évolution du rapport de
force intra-majorité sénatorial où on
voit que les républicains qui sont sur
une ligne très dure sur des sujets comme
l'immigration à travers la voix de leur
président Bruno Retailleau bien qui vont
être sans doute amenés à transiger avec
des centristes beaucoup plus modérés que
voilà ça va être voilà c'est plein de
Micro détails qui sont assez
passionnants à regarder il y a des
secteurs en détail et on va évidemment
les détailler mais peut-être d'abord un
mot sur l'ensemble finalement de ce qui
ressort hier de cette élection
sénatorielle qu'est-ce que vous retenez
vous Stéphane que finalement évidemment
ça bouge à la marge mais que dans
l'ensemble on est quand même sur une
stabilité sénatoriale oui c'est ça on
savait qu'il y avait assez peu d'enjeux
qui aurait que les lignes les peu bouger
peu évoluer mais je suis complètement
d'accord avec eux avec Jean-Baptiste qui
est intéressant c'est que on voit qu'il
y a quand même un tout petit recul ou
une stabilité qui est quand même une
forme de victoire pour les républicains
mais surtout une progression du du bloc
centriste entre droit entre l'Union
Centris horizon et je pense que ça c'est
intéressant pour la suite alors bon il y
a l'épiphénomène de faire l'épifié le
rendement par l'épis phénomène il y a
l'entrée de trois trois sénateurs
rassemblement national c'est le retour
du rassemblement national au Sénat parce
qu'il y avait déjà eu il y a déjà eu des
sénateurs rassemblement national au donc
c'est pas une entrée mais moi ce que je
retiens surtout c'est le renforcement de
ce centre droit et qui à mon avis peut
changer pas mal de choses pour la suite
notamment la suite du quinquennat et les
rapports entre le l'exécutif le
gouvernement le sénat et l'assemblée par
ricochet ça ça va être intéressant on va
revenir dans le détail sur ces résultats
on va continuer notre tour de France des
résultats dans vos départements on va à
Perpignan où on retrouve pierre Mathis
bonjour Pierre merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes rédacteur en chef du
journal L'Indépendant et Pierre on se
demandait si des sénateurs RL allez être
élu dans votre département ça n'a pas
été le cas les républicains font Grand
Chelem
oui républicains font le grand chelem
ils le font parce que ils ont su bien
préparer cette élection il n'avait que
deux candidats il n'y a pas eu de
dispersion souvent ici dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales la dispersion est un
petit peu la marque de fabrique là il y
avait peu de candidats donc ils ont fait
le plein de leur voix alors ils l'ont
pas fait au premier tour il y a eu
besoin il a été nécessaire de voter sur
les deux tours quand on rassemblement
national ils ont fait au deuxième tour
le plein de leur voix pas beaucoup plus
au premier tour ils ont fait plus et là
c'est vrai qu'il y avait une deuxième
candidature au sein du rassemblement
national une candidature un petit peu
ambigu une une conseillère municipale de
Perpignan qui a demandé à ne pas avoir
cette étiquette là et qui est dont
manifestement les voix sont allés chez
les républicains au deuxième tour après
être allé au rassemblement national au
premier
on voit là dans dans on va dire que dans
les Pyrénées-Orientales certaines
stratégies disons de de notabilisation
oui Oriane la région a élu deux
sénateurs du rassemblement national hier
dans le Pas-de-Calais d'abord c'était
assez attendu Christopher jurec a gagné
son siège au Palais du Luxembourg il a
38 ans c'est le premier adjoint de Steve
Briois à la mairie d'Hénin-Beaumont le
fief de Marine Le Pen et puis dans le
Nord ici à Lille ce n'était pas gagné
mais Joshua Hauchard a réussi à
s'imposer lui aussi il n'a que 36 ans il
était lu municipal à Denain et c'est un
proche de Sébastien Chenu il est donc
désormais sénateur rassemblement
national dans le Nord tout comme
Christopher Zurich c'est la première
fois un Cléo de France Élise des
sénateurs d'extrême droite alors
forcément l'ambiance elle était un peu
particulière dans les préfectures hier à
l'annonce des résultats à Lille et à
Arras les partisans du RN ont explosé de
joie et en réaction les troupes des
autres parties les ont fortement Hué la
scène s'est reproduite plusieurs fois
dans la soirée on peut dire que dans le
Nord comme dans le Pas-de-Calais les
sénateurs d'extrême droite ont été élus
dans les conditions assez similaires le
scénario et le même d'abord ils ont tous
les deux profité des divisions de la
gauche et de la droite je rappelle que
quand même dans le Nord il y a eu pas
moins de 16 litres c'est énorme pour
seulement siège de sénateurs à pouvoir
mais leur victoire il la doivent sans
doute sur tout au vote des mères ruraux
sans étiquette et même s'il faudra sans
doute attendre une analyse plus profonde
des résultats pour le confirmer a priori
ce sont ces mères ruraux sans étiquettes
qui leur ont apporté les voies qui leur
manque puisque le parti n'a pas assez de
conseiller municipaux pour faire élire
seul c'est des sénateurs et donc ce sont
probablement ces mers ruraux qui lui ont
apporté les voies de grands électeurs
qui leur manquent et pour les convaincre
les candidats RN ont vraiment sillonné
leur département et ça a visiblement
payé puisqu'ils ont beaucoup progressé
en nombre de voix tous les deux ils ont
presque doublé le nombre de voix des
sénatoriales par rapport à il y a 6 ans
donc on peut dire vraiment que
l'implantation du rassemblement national
dans le Nord et désormais très solide
puisque c'est la région qui offre au
parti de des trois sénateurs qu'elle
réussit à faire élire cette année merci
Samia merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous depuis Lille c'est l'un des
enseignements de cette soirée à Stéphane
le retour du rassemblement national au
Sénat avec un nombre inédite sénateur
ils seront trois c'est la preuve de la
notabilisation de ce parti oui moi je
pense que ça fait partie ça fait partie
des ça fait partie des enseignements du
scrutin mais c'était attendu aussi ce
qu'il faut regarder en fait au-delà du
nom de sénateurs et lui parce que 3
c'est c'est modeste entre guillemets
mais au-delà du nombre de sénateurs élus
regardez le nombre de voix qui ont été
totalisées par moi je l'ai pas encore
fait ce travail là mais je pense que ce
sera intéressant de regarder s'il y a
une progression parce que ça traduira
aussi la diffusion des idées la
notabilité ou la respectabilité de ce
parti d'extrême droite auprès des grands
électeurs donc des élus de ce pays et ça
je pense que c'est intéressant parce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on a on a aussi
du mal à mesurer je vous rappelle que de
l'élection en élection municipale parce
que 95% des grands électeurs sont des
conseillers municipaux on a une
progression très spectaculaire constante
et continue du nombre d'étiquettes de
liste sans étiquette mais des candidats
sont des étiquettes ne sont pas des
candidats sans idée et donc en fait il y
a pas toujours facile à évaluer donc ce
vote là et à mon avis il permettra aussi
de voir quelle est la progression du du
la diffusion des idées du du parti par
capillarité sur l'ensemble du territoire
et le nombre de de
députés qu'ils ont réussi à placer à
l'Assemblée
aux dernières législatives à mon avis
participent à ce mouvement là parce que
vous avez aussi ces gens en circo qui
diffusent leurs idées et qui sont
présents auprès des élus et c'est vrai
qu'on a beaucoup dit que le
rassemblement national était imparti de
scrutin national et qu'ils avaient du
mal dans les élections locales est-ce
que là cette augmentation du nombre de
voix dans des élections qui sont
typiquement des élections d'élus ça
prouve qu'ils sont en train de réussir
leur implantation locale je dirais que
ça dit deux choses c'est à dire que d'un
côté au niveau des idées
les élus locaux sont de plus en plus des
Français comme les autres donc la
porosité qu'on voit dans le dans la
population générale se ressent de plus
en plus chez des élus locaux qui dans
les petites communes en général ne sont
pas encartées donc peuvent comme
n'importe quel français être tenté par
par l'assemblement national et ça dit
aussi quelque chose de sociologie parce
que les élus locaux étaient assez
conservateurs pas forcément
conservateurs au niveau de au niveau de
grille idéologique mais en tout cas
conservateur dans le sens de pas faire
confiance à n'importe qui pour les
représenter au Sénat est-ce que l'on
voit c'est alors est-ce que c'était les
conséquences d'une forme de
notabilisation que le rassemblement
national essaye de mener au niveau local
ou à l'Assemblée nationale depuis depuis
quelques années en tout cas il y a
beaucoup moins de de scrupules de
prévenance à glisser un bulletin pour un
sénateur rassemblement national chez les
îles locaux et ça je ne sais pas si ça a
dit une sorte de succès de stratégie
d'implantation locale en tout cas ça
peut dire une sorte de succès d'une
stratégie de notabilisation
d'institutionnalisation du rassemblement
national on va voir les résultats en
Île-de-France certains résultats en
Île-de-France en tout cas on va aller
dans les Hauts-de-Seine on retrouve
Audrey Vitas bonjour Audrey merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous depuis
Nanterre Audrey une élection dans les
Hauts-de-Seine qui n'a pas été sans
surprise
oui pourtant on nous avait promis des
résultats nets éclairs à 18h30
finalement l'annonce a été faite à 20h30
après au comptage avec des scores dans
un mouchoir de poche première surprise
la liste LR avec 3 sénateurs sortant on
obtient que deux sièges seul Roger
carochi et Christine lavard de sont élu
Philippe msec et éliminé c'est
Marie-Dominique ashlimann tête de liste
dissidente à droite qui fait son entrée
au Sénat elle aurait bénéficié d'une
volonté de renouveau chez les élus c'est
ce que nous ont confié certains LR hier
soir et puis au centre la soirée a été
très belle Hervé Marseille le patron du
groupe Union centriste conserve son
siège il en gagne un autre sa seconde de
liste la modem Isabelle Floren devient
donc sénatrice dans les pas de son père
qui n'est autre que Jean-Marie vend les
Rambert le sénateur du Pas-de-Calais
qu'elle rejoindra à la Chambre haute et
c'est une première et puis ouf de
soulagement pour Xavier yakovelli le
sénateur macroniste qu'on disait en
difficulté ici dans les Hauts-de-Seine
il conserve son siège on l'a vu
rejoindre très longuement ces soutiens
après un dépouillement très tendu et
puis le dernier siège est septième siège
renouvelable revient au communiste
sortant Pierre rousolia qui avait réussi
à s'associer avec les écologistes et le
Parti socialiste mais il était amer hier
soir car sa liste manque un second siège
à 3 mois après un échec qu'il impute à
la liste dissidente LFI voilà qui
devrait donc faire parler au sein de la
nups Oriane merci beaucoup merci Audrey
vêtas pour ces résultats dans les
Hauts-de-Seine on va maintenant à Paris
on retrouve Steve Jourdain re bonjour
Steve Steve vous nous avez beaucoup
parlé tout à l'heure de de ce Grand
Chelem de la Gauche à Paris mais la
droite malgré ses divisions résistaient
oui la droite résiste malgré les
divisions puisqu'il avait pas moins et
bien de trois listes imaginées sur sur
la ligne de départ il y avait la liste
LR officielle menée par la sénatrice
sortant Catherine Dumas il avait aussi
une liste dissidente animée par Agnès
Evren la députée européen il avait enfin
une liste une nouvelle liste dissidente
menée et bien par le Sarkozy ce Pierre
Charon ont craignait une déperdition des
voix finalement ça n'a pas été trop
préjudiciable puisque la droite parvient
à conserver ces quatre sièges de
sénateurs ici à Paris Agnès evrain fait
son entrée au Palais du Luxembourg tout
comme Francis spinner le ténor du
barreau parisien et maire du 16e
arrondissement de Paris en revanche
Pierre Charron quitte le palais du
Luxembourg après 12 ans de bons éloyaux
services Oriane et
Alex à droite résiste mais la majorité
présidentielle elle est défaite
oui c'est Steve Oriane c'est pas c'est
pas
pour tout vous dire
il est juste à côté de moi là la
majorité présidentielle effectivement
qui s'effondre littéralement elle elle
avait jusque là et bien un siège de
sénateur à Paris on la personne de
Julien barjetton Julien barjetton qui ne
parvient pas à conserver son siège ici à
Paris ce qui a valu et bien cette petite
pique Dany dalgo là mère socialiste de
Paris qui en analyse on analysant les
résultats et bien disait que c'était le
sort réservé à ceux qui retournaient
leur veste Julien barjoton le rappelle
était un socialiste il était même
adjoint à la mère de Paris Anne Hidalgo
avant de rejoindre Emmanuel Macron en
2017 il ne parvient donc pas et bien à
conserver son siège qui n'est qu'une
demi surprise alors Yann puisque on le
sait le rapport de force et bien qui
sort de ce scrutin des sénatorial et le
reflet presque fidèle du rapport de
force qui existe au Conseil de Paris le
rapport de force de du de ce qui est
sorti des urnes omunicipales de 2020 ou
et bien Paris était divisé entre la
gauche et la droite de Rachida Dati la
majorité présidentielle c'était
effondrée et bien le scrutin d'hier
sénatorial a confirmé cette tendance la
majorité présidentielle qui est
littéralement rayé de la carte et bien
au sortir de ce scrutin hier à Paris
merci Steve merci
en quelques secondes
mesdames ce que nous disait si notamment
sur la majorité présidentielle à Paris
est-ce que Renaissance c'est le perdant
de cette élection sénatoriale
Jean-Baptiste
parce que c'est le le vrai perdant c'est
à Benjamin Griveaux et Agnès Buzin qui
voilà qui ont connu un fiasco assez
retentissant il y a trois ans municipal
même si même si il y a quand même
quelques quelques coups fourrés Julien
barjoton je pensais pas forcément son
titre soutenu par toutes les composantes
de la majorité présidentielle il y avait
cette liste dissidente LR de Pierre
Charron dont certains disent qu'il
entretient quand même d'excellentes
relations avec certaines personnes dans
l'entourage d'Emmanuel Macron aussi ce
qui a pu laisser penser à certains
autour de Julien barjoto qui lit que
toutes les voix macronistes vous la
majorité présidentielle n'était pas
forcément derrière lui voilà je pense
qu'on le saura
les deux ont été éliminés et en tout cas
s'il y avait un tout petit espoir pour
la majorité présidentielle de conserver
le siège de Julien barjoton
effectivement il s'est fracassé sur
cette division c'est l'échec Stéphane
pour Renaissance alors au-delà de Paris
c'est un échec où le fait que François
Patriat nous dise tout à l'heure qu'ils
vont réussir à se maintenir au dessus
des 20 sièges finalement c'est presque
un soulagement bah oui c'est les deux
c'est à dire c'est un échec limité on va
dire voilà en fait un des enjeux de ce
scrutin c'était c'est ce qui est très
bien dit Steve Jourdain dans sa
chronique quand il cite un Hidalgo qui
dit que Julien barjetton paye le fait
d'avoir retourné sa veste et en fait
dans ce dans ces sénatoriales les
sénateurs parmi les sénateurs
Renaissance vous en aviez un certain
nombre qui était dans ce qui sont
d'anciens socialistes et qui se sont
convertis au macronisme alors il y a de
l'inertie au scénar le temps est très
long en fait donc on a un certain nombre
de grands électeurs qui ont mis du temps
à réaliser qu'en fait en réalité
Emmanuel Macron n'était pas socialiste
et que et que ces gens qui venaient de
la gauche avaient finalement basculé ou
dérivé lentement vers un centre droit ou
une droite très affirmée et il y avait
un risque de correction et ben il est il
a eu lieu mais il est très limité parce
que s'il y a que trois sièges qui sont
perdus sur les 24 bah on peut dire que
voilà donc c'est un c'est un échec pour
la majorité qui définitivement n'arrive
pas à s'implanter dans les territoires
n'arrivent pas à progresser logiquement
au Sénat donc de ce point de vue c'est
un échec clairement et en même temps il
est très limité puisque c'est pas non
plus une correction on va écouter juste
Jean-Baptiste qu'on pense Franck Esther
c'est le ministre chargé des Relations
avec le Parlement il était il y a
quelques instants l'invité de Sud Radio
vous savez que le sénatorial c'est le
fruit des élections locales précédentes
oui et c'est vrai qu'on a pas gagné les
élections municipales départementales
donc on avait des ambitions raisonnables
on va perdre quelques députés au groupe
RDPI mais on a aussi des belles de
satisfaction je pense à l'Orne je pense
à la Loire je pense un certain nombre de
départements où on a gagné et on a
quelques défaites qu'on regrette
évidemment mais au niveau du Sénat c'est
une grande stabilité
bon tout va bien si on écoute Franck
Esther Jean-Baptiste tout va pas si mal
que ça effectivement perdre juste une
poignée de de sénateurs quand on sait la
calamité effectivement qui ont été les
municipales 2020 pour les macronistes
c'est c'est pas si mal mais c'est vrai
que pour continuer sur l'idée de
Stéphane sur cette force d'inertie qu'il
y a au Sénat où il y a toujours quelque
chose de différent sauf que le triomphe
Dany dalgo sur ses bons résultats qui
reflètent le triomphe de 2020 pour les
socialistes et un peu anachronique aussi
puisque faut quand même se dire que dans
la foulée de son score fabuleux à la
présidentielle les socialistes n'ont
plus un seul député à Paris
le rapport de force dans la majorité
municipale est en train de changer
énormément la France insoumise qui est
restée à la porte en 2020 et aussi en
train de se renforcer à bas bruit donc
si vous voulez la majorité de gauche en
2026 potentiellement reflète plus du
tout ce rapport de force en faveur de
nalida socialiste et on va parler
justement de la gauche Alex d'abord un
point avec vous parce que les élections
sénatoriales on le dit elles sont
marquées par la stabilité mais il y a
quand même des équilibres qui vont
évoluer
il y a des équilibres notamment à gauche
puisque le bloc de gauche au Sénat va
être renforcée les écologistes et les
communistes vont gagner quelques sièges
les socialistes également pourraient en
gagner quelques-uns en tout cas ce
groupe socialiste est conforté et ce qui
va être intéressant à regarder au sein
de la gauche et notoriale c'est de voir
l'influence de la ligne politique de la
nupes cette accord électorale de l'an
dernier autour de la France insoumise
aux élections législatives par exemple
il faudra voir si Eric kerouche le
sénateur socialiste va arriver à
détrôner Patrick canner à la présidence
du groupe socialiste au Sénat cela
voudra dire et bien que le groupe
socialiste est plus favorable à cette
ligne politique de la nupes mais c'est
une ligne politique que pourrait essayer
d'infléchir un certain Yannick Jadot qui
a été élu sénateur écologiste à Paris et
qui n'est pas très friand de cette union
de la gauche autour des insomnies et
avec son précise que l'émissibles qu'on
a vu là c'est une projection
effectivement c'est une c'est une une
estimation puisque dans quelques jours
il va encore y avoir des tractations
pour voir quel sénateur ira dans quel
groupe et donc ça va se finaliser dans
les pros dans les prochains jours un mot
sur la gauche puisque évidemment c'est
aussi l'un des enseignements la gauche
qui visait un ensemble de 100 sénateurs
le pari est presque réussi ou étant pas
en tout cas d'être réussi nous disait
Patrick canin ouais on va voir il faut
encore affiner les choses et puis voir
comment les comment les sénateurs se
positionneront moi ce que je regarde à
gauche ce dont on parle pas et qui me
paraît intéressant c'est le c'est la
progression des des communistes parce
que le groupe CRCE au Sénat était celui
qui misait le plus qui risquait le plus
en fait je vous rappelle qu'ils avaient
15 sénateurs si je me trompe pas et 11
sièges renouvelables ce qui est énorme
la plupart des groupes avaient la moitié
de leur siège renouvelables eux ils
étaient c'était c'était plus des plus
des deux tiers et avec une interrogation
sur en fait le recul d'un certain nombre
d'élus communistes et de dans les dans
les communes notamment autour de Paris
enfin bon il y avait il y avait pas mal
de questions et je trouve qu'ils s'en
sortent très bien ce qui est il y avait
même une bataille entre entre guillemets
évidemment entre écologistes et
communiste pour savoir qui elle est
réussir à passer devant l'autre alors
avec la volonté des écologistes de
passer devant les les commisses mais en
ça c'est de la c'est de la Guéguin
interne enfin je veux dire en terme de
symbolique où il peut être mais je
trouve que les communistes
s'en sortent a priori beaucoup mieux que
ce qu'on pouvait imaginer et je
suppose qu'on peut y voir la marque
aussi des des alliances qui ont été
faites dans une quinzaine de
départements et je pense que les
communistes avaient tout intérêt
effectivement à ces alliances là parce
que sans alliance pas sûr
c'était pas une étiquette nue sans elle
est-ce que là aussi ça veut dire quelque
chose je trouve ça rigolo est-ce que
vous avez de collègues tout à l'heure je
suis désolé j'ai oublié son son nom qui
était en scène en Seine-et-Marne qui est
en route scène pardon
Audrey merci qui qui parlait de qui
disait qu'en fait le la gauche avait
perdu un siège à cause de la liste
dissidente et les filles c'est pas une
liste décidante à partir du moment où
l'ensemble de la gauche Uni a pas voulu
y aller avec la France insoumise la
France insoumise a joué son jeu alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que la France
insoumise les insoumis ça fait très bien
qu'il n'aurait seul au qui n'avait
aucune chance d'avoir un sénateur ou une
sénatrice cellule s'ils sont allés tout
seul partout ils le pouvaient c'était
aussi pour montrer une espèce de
capacité de nuisance et ça montre bien
comment les rapports entre les uns et
les autres il va il va quand même
quelques quelques quelques réglages à
faire avec un une situation quand même
très rigolote ou très intéressante c'est
que à l'Assemblée la force de gauche qui
domine de la tête et des épaules ce sont
les insoumis au Sénat ils y sont
toujours pas et donc vous allez avoir
deux chambres avec deux espaces à gauche
qui vont avoir qui vont devoir apprendre
à dialoguer une recomposition et ça va
être un petit peu compliqué je pense
[Musique]